Speaker 1: Students in Nashville, Tennessee, the
site of a recent horrifying mass school shooting,
walked out, rallied and marched yesterday for
stricter gun safety laws for any gun safety
laws. And of course, we are yet again of mass
shootings that essentially no other country
has. And then we immediately say, some of us say
we have to do something and Republicans block the
idea of doing anything. And next thing you know,
we've moved on and it's the next mass shooting.
A couple of articles to look at. Chalkbeat
Tennessee reports. Nashville Students Rally for
Tougher Gun Laws as Governor Seeks armed guards
for every school. Some say armed the teachers,
maybe armed the students. Right. I mean, how
far are we going to go? More than a thousand
Nashville area students walked out of school on
Monday, converging outside the Tennessee state
capitol to demand stronger gun laws after last
week's mass shooting at a small private school in
the city. This started at 10:13 a.m.. It was a
week since Nashville police received that first
call about the shooter at the Covenant School.
Three children and three adult staff members were
killed. We have a little more information about
the shooting, The Tennessean reports. Students
demand gun control. Shooter fired 152 rounds
in about a 14 minute incident. And, of course,
that has to have something to do with the
guns employed. You're not going to do that
with a handgun. And so those who say this has
nothing to do with guns, by literal definition
can't possibly be correct. Now, I think
it's important to contextualize all of
these events. I mean, think of it a week ago.
Shooting in Nashville. Six dead, three kids,
three adults. Rallies, marches, demands for gun
safety. Republicans saying arming the teachers
and put armed guards in school. But meanwhile,
in this week, how many mass shootings have there
been? How many mass shootings have there been just
in the last week? Because yesterday there was one
in Baltimore. And I'm looking at my list here.
And of course, it's very hard to keep up because
there are so many. Yesterday, a mass shooting in
Baltimore and then also one in Mesa, Arizona. And
there was a mass shooting yesterday in Hampton,
Virginia. Another one on Sunday in Petersburg,
Virginia. The point is, just in the intervening
time between the Nashville shooting and today,
and we follow all of the lives affected,
Everything that's taken place, all of the
discourse and discourse may be a bit of a generous
term in some of these cases. We follow all of it.
There have been so many mass shootings since,
most of which you and I haven't heard of,
unless we went out looking for that information.
And so this really is an epidemic. We continue
to see one side that says don't do anything about
guns. And then we see our side say, listen, there
are things we can try. And again, I outlined last
week my ten point plan for things that we could
try. But there is an intransigent intransigence
and a recalcitrance to this discussion. And among
half of those who could be part of the solution
here. And so it's a great thing what the students
in Nashville did. And I continue to hope that
we can do something. We can't give up, as I said
last week, although it would be logical to think
maybe, maybe we should. What else can we do? We've
tried everything to convince these people that
it's worth at least trying some gun safety. But
we really can't give up because otherwise people
will continue to die. So good for the students in
Nashville, Tennessee. And of course, we will
follow whether any change does take place t